Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodassa
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sampuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sampuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So tonight, or this evening rather, just to go over this business of technique.
You know, a technique is there to perfect something, isn't it?
If you think about musicians or sports people, you know, they have their techniques.
Was it the frisbee flop just came to mind there?
The guy who started jumping over the bar
With his back, eh?
Frosbury, thanks.
Frisbee's one of those.
I knew it was close.
Frosbury flop.
So there you see, I mean that's a good example actually when I think about it, because people are jumping over this bar and using the usual technique of sort of, you know, just jumping over it, as you would as a kid.
And this kid, and this Frosberry, finds a way of doing it by throwing his shoulders over first, doesn't he?
The weight of his body and then sort of, he's almost doing a somersault really.
and of course the records go absolutely berserk so the aim is to jump over this bar but the techniques are different and if you get your technique right then you get over the bar so that in a sense tells us the relationship between a technique and your objective I'm also thinking of people like there was a violin playing I remember
Years ago, I think, Menuhin, is that how I said that right?
Menuhin, the violinist, he re-taught himself, I remember rightly, the violin under what was known as the Suzuki method.
Do you remember that?
Something like that.
And this gave him just that extra bit of expression in his playing or whatever.
I don't quite know what it did for him.
But he found that by doing this other technique, his violin playing improved.
So there is something about the connection between the technique and what it is you're trying to achieve.
And we can also say in the negative side that if the technique isn't right for what you're doing or isn't as perfected or is leaving something out of the skills then you tend to end up not as skillful as somebody else.
Another good example of that in sports is our great achievement in the last Olympics with 19 medals or something, wasn't it?
And I think it was a terrible thing for the Australians.
It was the first time we beat them, I think.
The thing is that what I discovered was that we'd filched a lot of their trainers.
See?
So now there's something else.
The person who is actually guiding the sportsman is also important in terms of getting the technique across, etc., etc.
Do you want to come up front?
You're all right, are you?
Just wave if you don't.
So if you look back at just in the recent history of Theravada there are at least two major techniques that come to mind which would be the Mahasi, the Mahasi Sayadaw's technique which he got from his earlier teacher and the one taught by
Goenkaji and Mother Sayama, I think that's how they referred to her, the Ubaken technique.
These are probably the two most used in the West and then on top of that you might say there's the more
easier or not so much easier less directed technique of in the forest in the Thai forest tradition of just observing the breath and whatever comes up it's very zen in a sense you know you just watch and you use the breath to get a certain level of concentration and whatever comes up that's your object you just watch it in a sense that's the basis of all technique but the little techniques that were
developed by these other teachers, just made the pointing just a bit more sharp, guided the meditation more to look more closely.
So that's, you might say, the importance of a technique as such.
It's just a way of practicing, a way of developing your skills of meditation.
And no matter how good the technique is, no matter how clever it is, it's of no use to the meditator if their actual aim isn't right.
That's another thing too.
It's no good learning the Suzuki technique on violin playing if you want to be a footballer.
It doesn't work.
Or even a thief, fiddling.
So we have to be very clear as to what state, what state of consciousness or what state in general we're trying to develop through vipassana.
That's very important.
And the first thing is to be clear as to what is not.
So if we know what is not, then at least we can be more clear as to what it is.
So it's not about directly healing the body.
There are many techniques these days to do with healing the body, going from something very physical like osteopathy to something on the edge like homeopathy, and then you get into all sorts of stuff.
And when you get into that, when you go into that, the person has a clear aim in mind.
They've got a physical problem and they're looking for help.
now we hear about physical problems being cured by vipassana I mean they are definitely headaches go backaches go there's that amazing example from the from the book from the Mahasi center when he was alive which is a compendium of all these cures that took place
it's on the web and perhaps the most astounding one is this man who comes in with stomach cancer and he's dying of it and he decides to take no medicine but just to sit in Vipassana and as he explains it there's an explosion in his stomach and it's gone
Now, of course, that suggests that whatever the cancer was, it was caused by the mental state.
It obviously wasn't something like asbestosis or something, or something that you can actually point to a chemical or a substance, which is mess the body about.
And one of the things that we come to realize in our meditation is that a mental state has a direct impact on the body.
We can feel it.
You know, if anger comes up, you can feel the heat in the body.
It's messing your cellular life about.
Fear comes up, you know, it's all constricting and tight, and you get these funny nausea feelings and stuff like that.
So it's not as though...
the mind isn't affecting the body, we know that, psychosomatic diseases.
And when you hear about vipassana, insight meditation curing diseases, when people say, well, you know, I used to have these terrible migraines and they've all gone now through vipassana.
Then the meditator thinks, well, you know, I've got this problem, so I'm going to sit.
And it skews, it skews the meditation because that's what you're looking for.
That's what you're trying to do.
You're trying to get rid of this headache, this backache, neckache, noseache, whatever has gone wrong, trying to get rid of it.
So all these techniques, noting, going slow, up and down the body, there's hundreds of them, are then all skewed over to this aim to try and cure the body.
now it may or may not you know hopefully it does but you miss out on the whole point of vipassana which is a spiritual insight which is to do with realizing you know ultimate truth for want of a better phrase and in the same way we make the mistake about therapy psychotherapy so all of us have some imbalance or other in our psyche I mean it's just the way we are because of our conditioning
and we know now through mindfulness training and CBT and mindfulness-based stress reduction that in fact there's some connection between the development of vipassana and mental purity, heart purity.
So therefore the meditator then begins to meditate in order to get rid of their psychological dis-eases, their psychological stress
And hopefully it does.
Hopefully it does alleviate the problem, as we see with something like mindfulness, stress-based stuff.
But, again, it sort of misses the point.
It's skewed off.
It's skewed off, you see.
And by doing that, again, we miss out on a deeper healing, which is the spiritual disease that we suffer from.
and that spiritual disease could be perhaps contained in the phrase, who am I?
And that would be a, or what am I?
Sort of digging deep at a deep sort of existential level, like what am I doing here?
Who am I?
Where am I going?
Why am I here?
That's even worse.
And
I think a person might have that approach, especially Westerners with our psychotherapeutic history, on the understanding, and to an extent it is true, that it is our psychological problems which are distorting the way we see.
But the Buddha's technique, the Buddha's way of teaching is actually to leave all that to the side and to move to an angle, to move to a position where that still is within the purview of our investigation but it doesn't become the purpose.
And we wouldn't do that unless we become more and more
confident, have faith in the system that these mental turbulences, the turbulences that we call emotional stuff, actually we don't have to do anything for them to heal themselves.
And that's a big leap for us because all our therapies offer us techniques about doing something about them.
and a lot of them are successful, I mean there's nothing particularly harmful about them, far from it.
So they're very clever techniques, they're very good ways in which therapists can help people overcome certain mental problems they've got.
But the understanding
you see, is that when you depersonalize, this is the point, when you depersonalize these mental diseases, they cure themselves.
What do we mean by depersonalizing it?
It means taking the I out.
And that's one of your main techniques, you see.
You're actually objectifying something, you're looking at it.
Whereas before, we say, we might go to a therapist and say, you know, I'm always depressed and I'm getting manic and I'm up and down.
And they say, it's I, I'm doing this, I'm doing that, I'm doing that.
And so the therapist gives techniques which may alleviate the problem, but it doesn't get rid of the I, because it's the I that's creating the problem in the first place.
When we take the I out, the me out, and we begin to see these mental diseases objectively, then we find certain characteristics about them, that in fact, by depersonalizing them, they lose their power over us.
Now you experience that in meditation when?
something, a memory comes up or something and you feel there's a bit of anger or a bit of depression or even a bit of excitement and joy occasionally, you know one, as it were, looks at it as an object and there's that disconnection with it not a disconnection in the sense of not feeling it, not knowing it but a disconnection whereby you're observing something very objectively
As you would watching that chicken that comes around here.
He's not been around actually these past years.
I frightened him.
I frightened her.
I barked and she ran out squawking.
I'm very good with animals.
There are two ducks as well.
They haven't come back either.
so it's like we're taking a position in ourselves where we can observe ourselves and that position of observation is not an abstract thing it's not an intellectual thing it's a direct experience of what it is that we're actually feeling so when pain comes up it's not as though we're by pulling out the eye by no longer saying
my knee is hurting I am suffering pain in my knee by pulling that I and me and mine out and your noting is pain there's pain see there is an object paradoxically we can actually feel it the keener because when the I steps in you get that resistance not wanting to be there fear of it see
so when an emotion comes up in a similar way depression comes up so our interior dialogue would normally be I am depressed and I am fed up with this depression there'd be some sort of identity with the depression and then in a sort of peculiar way that human beings do they find another identity which hates the depression
I'm fed up with the depression now.
So I am depressed and I'm fed up with being depressed.
And this sort of catastrophic way that we keep growing and growing around a central problem by resisting it and then resisting the resistance of it.
you get depression and you get fed up with this and then you get angry with it and then you get so angry you're afraid of it and then you get so afraid you really get depressed about how afraid you are and the whole thing sort of churns into this into this you know whirlpool of disaster and what we're trying to do is to take the I out of that to take the me out of that take the mine me my
and in so doing it loses that personhood, loses the personhood now when we do that
what do we find we find that it begins to diminish right begins to diminish sometimes it will diminish almost immediately sometimes soon as you pull out the thing begins to fade away sometimes it hangs on a bit longer it might hang on a day might hang on a month who knows but it always dies away and when it dies away when we're in that position and it dies away we realize actually I didn't do anything
it itself lost energy it itself began to undo itself, exhaust itself and then there comes this sort of feeling that what I'm doing with the heart is allowing it to express itself I'm sort of liberating, for want of a better word these pent-up states that are within the psyche, within the mind and our problem is
as meditators is how to keep maintaining that position of the objective observer the objective feeler often in the literature around vipassana you get this accent on observing, seeing and in a sense that only gives us half of the equation the other half is feeling the other half is bearing with in that very patient way just allowing things to arise and feeling them
And I suppose that's the big paradox, that these emotional states, this is not true of physical states, because the body has its own laws and its own separate existence from the mind, but it would seem that the mind cannot express, cannot liberate itself of these burdens save into some form of consciousness.
either you feel your emotional distress as an emotion or you feel it in the body as a discomfort or as a pain at worse as an illness if you think of it as turbulence that's the way I think about these things it's just turbulence like the weather it's a turbulence
Somehow we've caged it in, we're holding it through resistance, through fear and through aversion.
And we normally express that by simply not looking.
And that's basically what Freud discovered through repression.
I mean, it's a brilliant discovery.
Remarkable discovery.
It was completely unknown as far as I understand in the West.
The whole mechanism of how human beings in ignoring something actually push something away.
So whatever techniques we employ, the whole purpose of them is to get us into that position of the objective feeler, the objective observer.
That's all it is.
and one of the main technique that the Mahasi developed was this business of noting now the reason for the noting is not just simply to point us to the object to keep the attention on the object it does that very well if you do it consciously that's the first thing
if you get into the habit of noting, the rising and falling, rising and falling, that also becomes conditioned in the mind, right?
And our experience is that, you know, we're off in Acapulco somewhere, and when we come back the mind's happily going, living, falling, rising, falling, like we've taught it to do that, in which case, of course, it's absolutely useless.
There's some connection, there is a connection,
between the intellect, the words, the concepts and the intelligence this intuitive intelligence which is observing we confuse this intuitive intelligence with the intellect but the intuitive intelligence is using the intellect to talk to itself, to tell itself what it knows otherwise you wouldn't know it's a paradox, one of these things
but our confusion is that this intelligence is the intellect and therefore the cleverer a person is the more intelligent the more intuitive intelligence you think they have but that's not necessarily so and that's the separation between cleverness and wisdom not necessarily so
So that's the first purpose, is to use the intellect as something which keeps pointing the attention at the object.
See?
Keeps pointing it there.
And if you get into the habit of it, it's quite remarkable.
It takes a time, it takes time, it takes effort, and it takes continual effort.
The noting comes quite easy.
And one of the reasons why the noting comes quite easy is because in a retreat of this nature, or a Mahasi retreat, in fact all retreats, there's an awesome amount of repetition during the day.
so you get up and hearing hearing right because the bell that's the that's the every morning you wake up hearing hearing is it so after three or four or five days you wake up and hearing hearing it becomes quite natural yeah
and then you know brushing your teeth brushing brushing so eventually you find that your day doesn't give you a choice I mean that's what a good meditation retreat ought to do it shouldn't give you a choice you shouldn't be saying shall I sit or shall I not sit or I think I'll do some walking now I might go for a walk see all that is taken away from the meditator because it becomes a distraction
You know, you're fed up and you think, well, I don't think I'll sit now.
I'll have a cup of tea.
Whereas actually you're supposed to be sitting watching this fed-upness.
So, the noting, because of the repetitious nature of a retreat, becomes quite easy and normal, becomes quite straightforward.
And the noting can be both as to what it is,
you are experiencing so if it's pain you're saying pain pain but it can also be the process that you're actually experiencing so hearing you see might be just hearing where you're observing just what's happening within the mind within the heart and at the eardrum this sound you're interested in the process of hearing
and a word obviously cannot contain the whole of that experience because there's a part of you which is hearing like this little black bird and there's a part of you which is giving you pictures of the bird and where it might be and etc.
etc.
and there's a part of you which is responding a sense of joy, you know, birdsong so there's lots of things going on there
and what we don't want to do is start thinking about it because then we lose the direct experience so the word-like hearing as it were contains the thinking mind holds it there in a sort of limbo it can't think it's not producing a train of thought but it's actually acting as a push behind the observing to make you actually look and that's the purpose of the
of the noting in terms of vipassana in terms of the intellect itself and why we need to shut it down it's because everything that we experience is always being filtered through our past experience it's always being distorted by what we've experienced of this thing in the past when something comes along that we've never experienced before
then you get what these pictures in the room tell us you see especially that little girl you see now there's no you know she's so enthralled in looking at that butterfly and reaching out to it that she's no words for it she's no concept about it this is something very new and therefore the thinking mind has stopped there's just the that gaping mouth you know the jaw drops
and you look a bit gormless.
But actually, that's when your intuitive intelligence is at its most lively.
Yeah?
When I mentioned this, I was at a monastery up in the Algoi Alps, would you believe?
It's the forest monastery set up by Ayya Khema.
Lovely, beautiful place.
Unfortunately, well, I say unfortunately, the teaching is all in German, so I should speak German.
The monk there, he speaks very good English, the actual Jnana Bodhi, he speaks English.
And the other two monks with him, Kasapa, I've forgotten the other's name now, they're also excellent English speakers, so you could stay there.
Oh, what was I going to say that?
What was I saying that for now?
Where was I?
Oh, yeah.
The jaw dropping.
That's right.
When I said that in this talk, a woman came up to me afterwards and said that her father would say to her to close her mouth or a bee would fly in.
And that's what we do with children.
We don't see that.
In fact, they're actually really alive and taking stuff in.
But outwardly, of course, you look gauntless.
And if...
If an adult does it, then you think they've got learning difficulties, isn't it?
But actually that's the sign of the complete newness of an experience, complete openness to it.
So, when we have an experience and the intellect comes into it, by intellect I mean images, thoughts, concepts, ideas that we've gained from past experience, it always distorts the immediate experience because we're looking at it from that history.
So, just take a very simple example, you see, fruit.
Remember, every time you taste, every time you eat an apple, you're not just eating that apple, you're eating all the apples you've ever eaten.
because all the apples you've ever eaten have congregated into this idea of an apple and when you taste that apple it's either good or bad or it's not sweet enough, it's not firm enough and all those are comparisons the apple itself is just an apple and it has its own characteristics and it may be soft or hard, sweet or sour but that apple is unique in itself
but we don't see it like that we see it as part of Apple big Apple with a capital A Apple and we've got this line which says these are good apples and these are bad apples and this fits somewhere here and don't buy them again so all the time all the time we're doing that all the time we're doing that it's very very difficult for us to establish this open-mindedness this real
unadulterated observation and that's one of the reasons to develop this abiding in the present moment because it's exactly what it's developing you see exactly the qualities of open-mindedness open-heartedness equanimity to me that's the the root virtue of equanimity that it it it